china accounts for 40
of 6g patent application survey sales so
if you look at uh this is not even 5g
we're talking 6g not 5 6g apparently
it's 10 times faster than 5g so china's
6g development had been expected to slow
due to sanctions against huawei imposed
by the us government under president
trump but china has maintained its
competitiveness by mobilizing state-run
companies and universities around 20 000
patents applications were surveyed for
nine core 6g technologies including
communication quantum technology base
stations and artificial intelligence
china topped the list with 40.3 percent
of all 6g patent filings followed by uss
35 then japan's 9.9 in europe 8.9
south korea 4.2 the upcoming generation
of mobile communication technology which
is said to be more than 10 times faster
than 5g is expected to un enable fully
autonomous driving high definition
virtual reality and worldwide internet
connections even in remote deserts
even in remote deserts
why would china
want to have it's interesting they're
trying to control obviously because can
you imagine if you know how uh uh elan
wanted to go out there and put the
uh what do you call it the
satellite up there to be able to offer
uh wi-fi to everybody for free and it
was gonna start off slowing all this
other stuff guess what's the one country
that wouldn't want that to become a
reality yeah it's china china doesn't
want that to become a reality are you
kidding me free internet for me to be
able to log on and see what's going on
more the freedom of information it's
more the the free flow of information no
doubt about it they wouldn't want that
to happen can can you pull up 6g versus
5g everything i know about 5g and 6g
i'll be honest i i know from
valuetainment you you spoke with i
believe it was a gentleman from the cia
about this uh spalding yeah about a year
general spaulding uh about a year back
and he basically said if you let uh what
is it highway how do you uh how do you
pronounce that oh yeah
they're um
huawei huawei yeah huawei if he's like
if you let them in then
you you've just given them all your
information they all they do is just
farm information they come into these
countries and they give them free access
to you know free fiber optics free
satellite access the free free internet
free everything and what all they're
doing is just taking all the information
they possibly can here's what i want you
to do go back type in in search
uh okay go to images that you did you
did it right now go to images and then
click on the one all the way uh right
there the telecom network progression
bottom left second row right there this
tells you the difference click on it
again to make it bigger so everybody can
see it go a little higher go a little
higher go a little right there press
control plus
to make the screen a little bit bigger
and you can say no thanks to that
okay
what is it so here we go
1g
introduction year was 1979. terabyte
watch this it downloads a movie
in six days 1g 2g 91
one movie in two and a half hours 3g one
movie in two minutes 4g one movie in 20
seconds
5g one movie in uh
three movies in one second 6g is 300
movies in one second
this right here
this right here 3g that that was a game
breaker for napster bro when you could
download 100 songs on limewire and
napster until you gave yourself 15
viruses on your computer that was a game
changer i don't even think that's
accurate though 3g i never got a movie
in two minutes one downloaded a movie in
two places
it says three gigabytes there's so
there's some movies on some sites that
begin with x that you know you only need
but three four minutes of the movie
because three gigs right right now on 5g
won't take you one second
shout out to to the great
miss benz for for her many great
performances on the movies that i would
download
and uh well we can tell what you did you
know
how you think i got these forearms aaron
at least don't reveal it to everybody
keep your secrets to yourself by the way
you know what would be very weird if
they mandated masks in porn it'd be very
uh
that's when you know we're going to lose
the country if that happens i'm sure
there's importance where people are
masculine yeah mast and unmasked porn
yeah i mean i'm sure
people that want to keep it appropriate
yeah
so just gotta be safe i'm gonna be safe
wasn't there some guidance about like
doing a doggy style with the thing oh my
god i think there was something in
california i have an unbelievable story
about it i can't tell it on this podcast
because i think we'll get kicked off but
i have an unbelievable story about that
wait did you did you bring a mask
i told him the story
yeah i was dating his i was dating this
girl she was a ballerina in brooklyn and
they put out a
de blasio's health department put out a
list of do's and don'ts and she
beautiful girl but the hyper hyper hyper
crazy with this stuff and
she was going to follow these dues or
don'ts and
she was i'm not going to keep it to
yourself yeah keep it to yourself you
can tell us afterwards so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]